bang-bang coming to you live is not
really once again got Polina here hello
I'm wearing a shirt like that
are you really hitting this with Tiger
Qing intros right now yeah alright we're
gonna have a conversation with the
talent to see if she's invited back
after this you can't go rogue like that
it's not allowed uh there's a lot going
on in the world today I appreciate you
guys tuning in as well she's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get a lunch money right this new show
will come to you noon ish ish because we
don't have our [ __ ] together could be at
noon before noon afternoon or maybe five
o'clock with Polina here obviously we
try to be a little bit more prompt and
try to be a little bit better organized
she's got notes and topics so here we go
the first one Softbank and we work
what's going on with that Softbank has
pulled the three billion dollar tender
offer for rework shares all right this
is a big deal because we work basically
as a complete [ __ ] show
and I saw earlier that somebody was like
oh we work sin to get screwed because of
the real estate market in New York and I
tweeted and said no we were gonna get
screwed because we work was stupid
basically so what was the three billion
dollar tender offer so my question here
was you know we work hard II had cold
feet it was reported a few weeks ago
people were nervous that it would kind
of back out of its commitment to buy
back three billion dollars worth of
shares that was negotiated last year my
question here is does that mean that
Adam Newman doesn't get his billion
dollars yes it's the whole idea was that
Softbank the largest investor had agreed
in writing signed contract to buy back
three billion dollars for the shares
from other investors from Adam Newman
and from employees to build a bigger
position and basically they were gonna
provide this like liquidity event to the
company now all of a sudden something
says we're not gonna do that that
includes Adam Newman not getting his I
think with mentor 70 million dollars
that he's not gonna get now along with
all of the other investors benchmarks
got like 350 million dollars they're not
going to get etc right but if you
remember
certain conditions that had to be met in
order for south bank to provide to buy
back the three billion that's true some
of those conditions were unfulfilled
including the failure to obtain the
necessary antitrust approvals by April 1
2020 which was yesterday um so there's
basically gonna be a legal battle here
right I think benchmark and others have
said hey we're willing to pursue
litigation on this soft banks basically
saying well here's a bunch of things
that were supposed to happen to haven't
happened I don't think you and I are
gonna solve this right now but in
desperate times especially in financial
crisis like this there's a lot of
jockeying that goes on and people make
reputations or break their reputations
and we've seen people pull term sheets
and you know all kinds of bad activities
obviously this is another one oh I
thought it was interesting not one of
the conditions says that existence of
multiple new actions by governments
around the world related to Cove in 1900
was we weren't supposed to predict Cove
in ninety they probably had some kind of
you know end of world clause or
something like that hey by the way I
just noticed nobody joke there's Oreos
back there why do you think they're
sitting well listen sometimes we gotta
have a little fun on here alright next
is not so much fun unemployment numbers
today the jobless claims came out for
the last week if you remember last week
it was the largest increase ever in
jobless claims three point two eight
million Americans the high before had
been just under 700,000 back in nineteen
eighty two this week unfortunately we
saw six point six million Americans file
for unemployment claims that's about 10
million new claims over the last two
weeks and what that does is it puts us
what around nine percent unemployment
the United States yeah
and this is this is the thing that I was
worried about the chief investment
strategist that Charles Schwab said
sadly this probably underestimates the
actual numbers because of the overload
and the systems and not every call
getting through I was clearing my throat
just being safer okay I need some more
social distancing so yeah so not
everybody's actually getting through so
the that number is actually in under
yeah well there's a couple of
contributions to that right I think one
of them is the fact that people can't
get through look literally last week in
me I think it was New York and Texas
there was 1.7 million people who called
and tried to file claims but only
230,000 of them are so got included
we've obviously seen some of them get
through now but there's still more
people who haven't been able to file
then you get things like the gig economy
rights all the freelancers all of the
drivers etcetera they're not eligible
for unemployment because they were a
1099 employees and things like that and
then you also just get people who either
are undocumented workers or they don't
apply right so kind of the real
unemployment number is much much higher
and unfortunately I think it's gonna
continue to get worse over time yeah
absolutely it's really sad it is really
sad but the best way to fix the economy
put American businesses back to work get
American workers back to work
obviously there's a health crisis going
on but we're going to have to eventually
solve the problem that way so we'll see
how long that takes
that leads us to FBI masks speaking of
the health crisis this story is wild and
highly complex why don't you give the
overview so basically there was this
Brooklyn man who claims to be infected
at the coronavirus unclear but he got
raided by the FBI because he allegedly
peddled and stored massive amounts of
n95 respirator respirator masks in his
home and he's also suspected of selling
a New Jersey doctor a thousand of the
masks for $12,000 which was a markup of
roughly 700 percent okay so basically
what happened here is a guy's got a
bunch of masks the claim is he's got
5,000 masks and he's selling them at a
markup and the charges against him are
everything from him coughing on the FBI
agents no it's like a salt or something
and then also around medical supplies so
my take on this and then I want to hear
your take on it is this is a really
really slippery slope and I'll give you
kind of the extreme example of what I
mean so there's two pieces that scare
the [ __ ] outta me
the first is in the articles what it
describes is as the police approached
him he coughed without covering his
mouth not they don't describe it as like
they he walked up to him and coughed on
them like in an aggressive manner just
that he coughed and when he did that he
didn't cover his mouth if we if we enter
a world where it is illegal to cough
because of the of the virus right that's
an extreme example but if that's the
world we're going to that's a really
really dangerous world to live in
because now all of a sudden it changes
the way that people think about being in
public wearing masks for this watering
medications - there's little bells like
it was just it was emphasizing what I
said you see that do you think about the
masked part of this I think it's
ridiculous I think it's absolutely
ridiculous that you were trying to make
money when there's literally hospitals
are overwhelmed doctors don't have
enough masks it's just it's a time where
like if you're gonna be a douche bag and
that was not the time so I don't
disagree with you that there's a ton of
like the ethical components of this
right and the price gouging and all that
stuff is really bad but is there a
difference between him doing this and
companies doing it like aren't the
companies just selling the mass of the
hospital not at a 700 percent markup
true that's definitely true but I think
that again slippery slope in that all
the sudden the government like the thing
the tweet that I saw was a Jameson lob
had this tweet where he basically
rewrote the headline to the article and
he said government confiscates citizens
private property because they disagree
with his investment decision right and
so I think it rigo's all of this goes
back to like how literal do you take the
Constitution right the protection of
private property versus in certain times
should they prevent him from doing this
and what they actually did I think it
you were telling me they confiscated the
masks and took them away Yeah right and
put them in there next to my so who
knows what they're gonna do with them
but just under certain times lead to all
of these nuanced questions and there's
there's no black or white answer of
course I'm like you know after 9/11
happened a bunch of things changed that
you could argue infringed on people's
privacy etc but I think in times of
global epidemic
we need to have these conversations but
probably
your ear mask your masks truth are you
she wants the masks in the hospital
which is actually a good thing when you
wear a cat shirt on here and you start
with hello you cats that's what we get
you've been practicing this do it no
because I'm sorry with what's up what's
up what's up all right what happened
with motion no she's a note-taking app
or so like a Productivity thing I forget
everyone describes themselves in some
weird way but it basically can like
replace the Google suite if you will the
G Suites so like Doc's note-taking
sheets all that stuff so right now in a
time where all these startups are laying
people off they're very they're very
uncertain about future fundraising
notion went and raised fifteen million
dollars and a two billion dollar
valuation fifty five zero five zero from
investors including Index Ventures and
others notion had previously been valued
at eight hundred million so I mean this
is interesting right well the best part
is that they're profitable right are
they profitable yeah they've been
profitable for a while like two years
and they don't need the money but they
said that it was a signal of stability
we talk about this a lot it's right it's
a signal stability but don't you think
when you raise that big of a round you
become less disciplined with it uh well
it that that is one of the risks but I
don't think every company does that
right because they'd only raised like
less than twenty million bucks I think
previously and so all the sides may
raise you have seventeen million so it
says yeah plane has got the note she's a
smart one remember when I told you guys
that the smart people got notes she got
the notes I got the [ __ ] so it works
perfect
yeah they raise fifty million dollars
and it's a big valuation but they're
profitable and it gets a very small team
I think they got less than 50 employees
and so it's one of these things where
like right now for a company to raise
capital only the best companies are
gonna be able to raise capital a lot of
it at great terms and you're just
building a war chest if you ever touch
it
right then you basically just have the
money in case things go absolutely
sideways but why not take the money in
the end
think that if you're a profitable
company that's kind of the only way to
raise money right now or do you think
everybody should be trying to raise
money well this goes to the whole
conversation around bailouts right which
is a lot of the bailouts are companies
that mismanaged their businesses
previously so well basically what happen
is I take the airlines they spent
majority of their free cash flow on
buybacks which there's nothing wrong
with a buyback as a way to return
shareholder value it's a very tax
efficient way to do it etc but now they
need that capital and so rather than run
to the government and say hey give me
the money what they shouldn't be doing
is they should be trying to raise
capital whether through the equity or
debt markets and go to private investors
the problem is that there's a
dislocation between what the investors
believe the business is worth and what
the executives believe the business is
worth right and so the whole argument is
like well how much would you buy United
Airlines for if it would you buy it for
$1 like the stock no like that for the
whole company you pay $1 yeah would you
pay $100 yeah okay would you pay a
hundred million dollars yeah why not I
don't know but if you had the money then
it's six point five billion dollars
inhibitor last year's I am okay right we
do for a billion dollars probably right
yeah so like there's a market to be made
you might be a better CEO but like the
whole point is that people are willing
to buy the company at some price it's
just there's a disagreement on that
price what they do is they run to the
government and the government gives them
advantageous terms because it's like a
startup running out of money trying to
go to investors to get money literally
that's what's happening but it's
happening in the public markets with a
big fortune 500 company cetera in the
private markets right this happens all
the time so how many companies are gonna
die over the next three months in
private startup world right they just
run out of cash a lot of them yeah
they're not gonna get bailed out so
notion putting money on their balance
sheet basically as a way to signal hey
we're here for the long term is a
startup so how could you have even
foreseen the magnitude of an event like
this like how how much money do you
think as a start-up founder you should
have in the bank for a rainy sunder well
this is this little thing so there's
companies that basically say hey look
I've got 12 months of capital I've got
12 months of running
18 months 24 months right as an investor
like what is the norm in all depends
rate depends on how big you are how much
cash you're burning right cuz you can
also manipulate that in this offensive
let's say that if I'm burning a million
dollars a month and I've got 12 million
dollars and I got a year of runway yeah
but if all of a sudden I then lower my
burn to 500k bricks that lasing people
off I save cost whatever I have to do
now listen have two years of runway
right so it's kind of a moving scale but
old totally winds up happening is
entrepreneurs have to remember that
strong balance sheets matter and on top
of that the number-one rule of business
don't run out of money right if you run
out of money it's over it's like you
can't win the game if you're not playing
the game anymore right and so I think
that a lot of these companies that's
what they're facing they got to go to
the markets to get money agree just be
profitable whoo got her to agree that's
the first one for today we'll see if I
can get her to agree more all right last
one this one's a fun one I feel like all
the doom and gloom of Softbank we work
unemployment numbers in the FBI we had
to end with a with a positive one potato
head okay so you know zoom and like how
we're all on doom now well this company
was having a meeting with all its
employees and the boss join doom and I
guess she somehow opened the filters
section I know how to do that but she
turned herself into a potato and then
she genuinely couldn't figure out how to
change her back so the entire meeting
all these people are normal and then
there she is talking about serious
things as a potato it's it's really
great I mean that's absolutely I would
do but like it's hysterical at the fact
that she went through the whole meeting
and then I think the reason why people
know that this happened is because one
of the employees took a photo and
tweeted it and the the tweet went viral
of of like the co-workers all standing
there you know sitting at their desk
normal and their homes accessor and then
there's just this potato head in the
corner that's the boss she's like I was
so confused as to why I was a potato of
all the things I could be why a potato
hey some people like potatoes that's
fine
you ever seen Toy Story as a gray movie
mr. Potato Head
great movie
is Toy Story you're seeing it yeah you
never seen Toy Story so so I think I've
seen it but I just like I you know I
grew up not here yeah you grew up in
with a buncha win a choice right come
out in the 90s yeah when you were born
you were born in the 90s and you've
never seen Toy Story no because I was in
Bulgaria we were watching movies one day
reach from the sky yes Buzz Lightyear ya
know who is Buzz with machine ok guys
it's been a great day remember while
Wall Street's trying to get rich the
rest of us are trying to get our lunch
money right and she brought the lunch
box which by the way this doesn't look
like a lunch box no this doesn't look
like a lunch box this looks like a
makeup kit or something else it's not a
lunch box is an example of the bully
taking the lunch box
don't touch the lunge joyfully yeah it's
a grounded all right well listen well
Wall Street's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right clean and I appreciate you guys
listening to all this every day noon ish
why noon ish because we don't got our
[ __ ] together my baby before noon
afternoon right at noon or at 5:00 p.m.
she doesn't like when I say all that
song keeps saying it to keep you guys
laughing and we will see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]